[Laughter]
uh good evening uh members officers
ladies and gentlemen welcome to this
meeting of the development committee on
the 7th of December
2023 there there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm goes off please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
through the nearest fire
exit please use either the fire exit
through the main doors of the hall or
the fire exit in the store room adjacent
to the the
stage the fire assembly point is in the
island in the front of the main entrance
of the building please do not
delay sorry about
that uh please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council
staff please note that the meeting will
be live streamed and lastly please
switch off your mobiles or turn them to
[Music]
silent okay members of the public while
you can of course film or take
photographs during this meeting this
should be done without disrupting the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask if you to
raise your hand clearly in the air if
you wish to take photographs or film
this evening
I see no hands so thank
you voice will only be captured on the
live stream when your
microphone to switch on your microphone
when you are invited to switch off again
when not
speaking members voting will be done on
a show of hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands for and then against
recommendations and we'll also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from the vote
apologies for absence we have received
apologies for absence from councelor
Meyers councelor Knight councelor
Stanley and councelor
laurman councelor Williams is
substituting for councel
Myers agenda item three non-members
attending uh we have two we have councel
Orton and councel
lambor and councel sorry you have
three
minutes of the meeting held on the 23rd
of November 2023 are the meeting are the
minutes agreed
members uh councelor Wilson thank you
chairman could I just propose uh two
very slight amendments on page three um
the paragraph that starts it's
the councilor Hoy moved a motion um and
it says that it's plastic recycled
rubber recycled rubber particles
similarly on um where the resolution was
made it's the same thing so it should be
plastic comma recycled rubber
particles okay members with the
inclusion of those uh small variances
are we
agreed thank
you okay Declarations of Interest
members do we have yes council is Shaw
just to declare that I'm an Essex County
counselor as well as an RDC thank you
okay anyone
else uh I have two items uh where I have
to declare an interest uh the first
one is on the uh
item item eight which is glazebrook Farm
uh this is actually on the plot where I
have my factory so I will be um I will
be withdrawing from the debate on that
one uh in the interest of um uh complete
impartiality of the the committee and
also
for item nine Brook Road uh the
applicant here is in the same industry
as me and I know him although I have not
actually spoke spoken to him about this
issue and I have no uh known interest in
the actual item but um I just declaring
an interest in that to be
clear other than that do we have any
other Declarations of
Interest no
okay okay we'll move on then to agenda
item six uh this item is brought forward
from the last planning committee
apologies to those who had to come back
on this one again um and and I'd like to
hand over to uh Mike strength who will
present rol thank you thank you chairman
um this application is to a site south
of the settlement of uh East End pagam
if where I'm Focus now is the plow and
sail Pub if members are familiar with it
quite a tight-knit little village in the
settlement pattern our site is down this
access track away from the pub and the
village and down into this part here and
we're interested in this
uh sort of u-shaped building that you
see uh in the area triangular shaped
site here so it's this access road or
the extension of the access road and the
existing building if we widen out
slightly we'll see the buildings that
members saw at a site visit a little
while
ago um this is actually a repeat
application of something that members
approved in 2019 that recently expired
and you'll see it's a sort of stable
Light Building build buildings with uh
single doors uh leading out onto an
enclosed area access through this way
pitch roofed it's a brick construction
with uh tiled roof um currently vacant
or has been in use for some small minor
uh domestic uses storage and the like um
members saw at the site visit that the
adjoining areas were all grassed over uh
and naturally as you might expect this
time of year the site was relatively
overgrown if we can jump to the propos
plans please um this is an application
to convert that building there are some
extension works you'll see in the
courtyard to create a corridor either
side and one of the units is for a
two-bedroom uh holiday let and the other
side of the building is for a
three-bedroom holiday L you'll see that
it makes use of the existing building
there's no height increase or any other
extension other than the corridors that
I pointed out in the uh Central
Courtyard
yard The Proposal Accords with policy in
terms of giving an existing building
which is in the
green Accords with policies you have on
diversifying the rural economy as Holly
lets do there's not only the spending
power of people who may be uh staying
there temporarily but there's also minor
jobs cleaners maintenance things like
that that also provide jobs uh in the
local
area though the submitted um bat survey
was out of date with the application
um owner would nevertheless be
responsible for any species that are
found in the conversion um but officers
are comfortable that although usually
two years is is a required uh period
that there probably won't be any
substantial findings there wasn't before
other than um to do with a barn now that
is nesting in the site and the
mitigation as with the previous
application is that in a tree in the
locality whilst The Works are being done
a mbx be provided and then in the Loft
area there is a proper Nest box
installation in in the roof so the
ecologists previously were were happy
with that um in flood RIS terms the area
is in uh flood zone 3 and you'll see
from the report the details that in
event of a breach of the seaw wall
something like a Poseidon or an
earthquake something like that that
would crack the seaw wall open the area
would be inundated I explain it that way
because what usually happens when you
have high tides you get warning you know
the weather conditions conspire such
that the pressure Over the Sea causes
tides to be held back or whatever in a
certain way so that when the moon
rotates and they come back in they're
doubly high that causes over topping and
sometimes washing out of the back of the
wall and then the fracture that's that's
what tends to happen so in those
circumstances people living in these
areas if they're signed up to it get
warned by the environment agency that
it's best they EV evacuate or Retreat to
a high area in the building so they get
a warning and that's how this
application turns if these were
dwellings where somebody was going to
live they'd be too vulnerable because
that's their home but when they're a
holiday let the people in the let can be
warned bring their holiday to a
premature end and leave and go home
wherever that is so because that
vulnerability is less you're seeing the
recommendation that although the
environment agency held holding
objection to this which is sometimes
neither one thing nor the other back in
2019 they didn't object they felt that
the ca defenses and the managed Retreat
that they um that they follow was
adequate but you'll see in response to
this more recent application they've
they've suggested that there's a there's
a holding response but it seemed to turn
to officers on the basis of whether the
council's emergency planning officer
would allowed evacuation members will
know what happens in event of these
things perhaps a Sports Center or
somewhere is opened and kitted out for
48 hours or so until the uh the risk
abates and then people go about uh their
daily lives well in this case it's
anticipated that a holiday dweller
wouldn't need accommodation as such they
would um go back home because that's not
this would not be where they live so on
that basis chairman the recommendation
has previous year's approval subject to
the conditions set out in the
report thank you uh there is one public
speaker for this item the speaker is Mr
Slater who is speaking in support of the
application Mr Slater please take your
place at the
microphone you will have uh five minutes
I'll give you uh warning when we come to
one minute towards the end thank
you councilors and uh officers um as Mr
TR FR has pointed out we're seeking an
alternative use for these or for this
building uh in
pagram it's a building that my wife and
I have owned for 25
years um it's had almost
Contin up until 2019
that's
covid it is substantially built of panal
roof over the years we have uh rebuilt
the roofs some of the roof Timbers and
reused all of the original concrete
pantiles sorry the clay
pantiles uh H how our whole aim has been
to conserve the the building and not
change them in any great form which of
course this application as you can see
they are uh there isn't any material
change other than the internal corridors
um to access the the uh various
rooms
um we appreciate the rural nature of of
the site having lived in pagam uh we see
visitors coming to enjoy the birds and
the SSI River Bank along the uh the
roach and of course wacey Island which
is increasingly a draw for for people
coming to study and look at the bird
life H and my knowledge there really
isn't anywhere where you could offer
accommodation to people uh in that
situation um
the track and roadway as we've discussed
is
um to be permeable it'll be a grasscrete
surface I know one of the councilors
raised this point and I think that was
the reason that it was it was called in
there were concerns over that we don't
want massive tarmac we don't want to
change things things uh we see it very
much as appreciating the rural nature of
pisham the bird life the owls with
putting up owl boxes um so it's not
going to be a a party destination put it
that way it is for people that
appreciate pagram and love pagam as we
do uh and to give them those people the
the opportunity to uh come along and
stay
thank
you thank you if you'd like to return to
your seat thank you very much for
that so are there any visiting members I
I I believe councelor won you wish to
speak would you like to come to the
microphone please thank
you as you know five minutes and uh I'll
let you know when it comes to one minute
thank
you thank you Mr chairman good evening
members uh first of all my thanks for uh
putting this on as the first item uh and
acknowledging that we were here till
quite late hours and it was a bit
disappointing to hear it ad journ last
time so uh my appreciation to that um
and uh just going through a few things
to begin with and my apologies to the
applicant that I called this in in the
early part of August and here we are
into December now uh and through the
elapse of time and the calling process
but um that is how the system works that
a report is issued and within a few days
you have to make a decision as to
whether you're going to call it in uh
and I did make that decision uh orbe it
it was never my intention to hold up the
application for the period of time so my
apologies on that um can I say at the
outset that personally uh I'm extremely
supportive of the outcome of what this
is trying to achieve in terms of holiday
lets to encourage tourism and small
scale employment in the area when I
first read the report um two things came
to mind and I'll be very honest with you
the secondary was about the back Sero Mr
shx has addressed that in part but I
found it just a little surprising that
2019 was recent enough not to have to
consider the issue of of bats again but
Mr shranks has covered on that um so
then we talk about potential flooding
and water retention now in the light of
an experience elsewhere in the District
where a permeable uh length of surface
was put down and I will say tarmac um
which T to in sense and purposes to the
laay person um is far from permeable the
alarm Bells started ringing when I when
I looked at it so if you look at
paragraph three it is proposed to
upgrade the existing track to a
permeable service surface and in the
light of my personal previous experience
of a permeable service it was far from
per uh far from permeable quite the
reverse so for me that was the concern
especially when we're talking about an
area like pagles where there is a
history of um surface water hanging
around should we say in certain
areas um and what I was concerned about
was that this application actually
didn't cause others um troubles where
flooding was concerned rather than to
the applicant themselves and really the
the flooding issue breaks down into two
issues it's a surface water and that's
covered quite adequately in paragraph 35
uh but it talks about a low risk of
surface water flooding we've talked
about bats um and Mr shrank has already
covered that quite adequately so we
won't go into paragraphs 38 and 39 but
then we talk about at paragraph 44 quite
a lengthy section uh running up to
paragraph 52 I think it is uh 50 there
else um but it talks about flood zone 3
and is identified by the environment
agency as as such um and then it talks
about in paragraph 45 uh the
environmental agency not um complying
with the requirements set out and
actually passing the responsibility to
Rochford District Council uh to justify
why they might overcome the environment
agency concerns so it's very good a one
agency to pass the buck to another
organization to uh um to pass the buck
on that um
but it does say in paragraph 46
colleagues in the environment agency
stated that the applicant can overcome
our holding objection by and then it
goes into a series of of issues how that
can be done uh a lot of detail about
flooding um and um talks about in
paragraph 50 consequently if a high
Refuge is not provided for Holiday lets
and it goes on it puts the hus on
Rochford District council's emergency
planner uh and talks about 53 on this
basis the safety visitors would be
assured there would be no commitment of
council resources in a flood incident so
there are no objections to the proposal
going ahead so it it minute presents all
these things and then it mitigates it um
so paragraph 53 makes it quite clear
that if rord District Council are happy
then the environment agency are happy
now we talk about holiday lets we accept
that we're not talking about permanent
homes here and people being displaced if
they live there so I think there's quite
a difference between habitable homes
where people are their full-time and
holiday L lets but interestingly enough
in the conclusion there's no real
reference to paragraph 53 so in the
conclusion it doesn't mitigate it but I
have to say chairman I've talked to
colleagues and I'm extremely grateful uh
to members for their site visit and my
mind is at rest now uh but it's taken
five months to put my mind at rest
because I really didn't want flooding to
be occurring in other parts of pagan
where I know that can be a bit of a
nuisance but I'm totally supportive of
what the objective is trying to achieve
thank you very much members thank you
chairman thank you councelor
[Music]
woodon uh committee members we have one
Ward counselor uh Mrs Shaw do you wish
to speak on the application yes please
thank you um I was actually on the
committee when this first come forward a
lot of the items have been resolved I am
still concerned I know Mr strength has
said about them that survey on why we
didn't have a new one done but I do have
to say I'm really very concerned about
the being in flood zone 3 there's it all
around the area when we heavy have start
again have Heavy Rain there is flooding
and as soon as it floods I always get
emails saying and photographs so I'm
very concerned about this very good
report but I'm still very concerned and
I'm afraid afid I cannot approve this
thank
you thank you councelor Shaw okay anyway
councelor
Ward thank you
chairman as I say the report is very
good and I'm I'm glad to see it covers
everything that is required within it
and I do appreciate what the officer has
actually done within the report and
highlighting again um there are various
things on page
6.12 uh flood risk assess M again I
think that's a very very important
factor in as much as that I have seen
long-term reports for the area which
show that unless the defenses around
that area are updated it will definitely
flood within the next 30 Years and
that's a big worry and no money is being
put in put being put in to Coastal
defenses I know we have RAM and we have
various other things but it's it's a
multi-million pound job job that needs
to be done and of course the money isn't
there so that gives me cause for concern
in a vast amount of that area which
would be subject to flooding and would
happen moving on from there I'd like to
again come to the item on
6.14 again it looks at where the
environment agency going through all the
various things uh looking at the risks
that are there now to
me I I am very concerned about the risks
and I'm about the insurance and if
they're saying it's down to us will we
be taking care of the insurance if we
pass this is this now down to this
Council to actually ensure that the
safety of those people who are there and
any damage is down to us because
basically they just passed the bu but
more important is loss of life and that
comes in the sequential test the
sequential test means if if something
were to happen would the people be able
to be rescued by the fire service or
anybody like that and that's a big
question which has not been answered in
this report whatsoever and I believe
because of that I would have to reject
this completely and couldn't approve it
thank you chair thank you councelor ward
councelor FD thank you chairman um
looking at the flooding flooding does
concern me and the report says it can be
mitigated which is a good thing because
we are looking at building in more flood
zones and they should be a to be
mitigated but it would put my mind at
ease with the U emergency planner
because these are people who don't live
in the area they're going to come and
stay on the holiday lit they won't know
where to go they won't know what to do
if this if there is a warning they might
not sign up to the was it the
environment agency's flood warning so I
think there would be need to be sign you
actually in the let telling them exactly
what to do and part of the terms and
conditions when they go and let it just
in case it floods that would put my mind
at rest and I would be able to support
it condition yeah thank you Council I'm
aware Council W you want to have a um
coming there um Mike can I just ask is
there anything that we can do condition
wise to allay the fears on that issue
yes chairman condition 11 is a new
condition in comparison to the old
consent all the other conditions that
are on there are the ones that were put
on in 2019 but as a result of the slight
change in the agency's advice condition
11 is introduced and you'll see that it
requires the owners of the holiday lets
hereby approved shall ensure that
visitors receive environment agency
flood warnings how that works is that
there's like a a sticker or um a label
laminated in each unit maybe in more
than one place then in the event of a
warning you shall do this or whatever
ring this number for the
owners they have uh their phone numbers
lodged with the environment agency so
when there's the slightest hint of there
being an issue you get woken up at all
times a day to hear the message so the
way it would work is that the owner
responsible for the unit would get the
message
through I mentioned that it may be some
local staff housekeeper or something
they would perhaps be alerted as well
and between them the tenants would be
advised that there's going to be or the
risk of a flood and that they should uh
react accordingly so it's not for the
tenants to necessarily come maybe from
outside the district and then log on the
app and and be warned it's for the
management of the facility to let the
the people tenanted there or or on
holiday there
no so usually they'll say there's
something visual in the unit itself and
then the people running it they're the
people who would pass the message on who
would be the recipients of the of the
warning okay thank you uh yes do you
want to come back coun yeah um I don't
quite see how that will work because I
know how the flood warnings work they
find you at home to you to go to High
Ground so if this happens at 2 o'cl in
the morning what it needs is a as you
say the cleaner or the owners to miss it
and they're very vulnerable on the coast
and does it have a landline would it
have a land line there will they be on
looking at
mobiles it could fall down quite easily
I'd like that strengthened a little bit
if we can chairman we we could do we
could ask for specific details to be
agreed such as landline that's been
suggested what extent of notification
how many people would be expected we
could have like a management plan detail
that would we could put into condition
11 to to give more scope of the kind of
level of things that we that we see but
if you take in some of these like
Holiday Camp Caravan Parks all over the
southern region or whatever they're all
got sometimes they got people on site
but not everybody if you go to a small
one that's that's perhaps like five or
six Caravans
somewhere the the
owners they're obligated to be in
attendance it's like a 24hour thing
because the weather doesn't work you
know office hours so it works elsewhere
in the
nation um but if members think it
satisfies as the test of reasonable I'm
not going to row back too hard against
that if it if it makes a difference and
gives members that Comfort but you might
be going extra to what is usually
required can I ask there then sorry if
uh would you be happy to take what has
been suggested here as
you you come up with just something to
firm up the conditions or do would you
be happier if we had a vote on specifics
no I think I think I can I can add to it
as your advisor I have to say that
you're probably going a bit far just so
that you know that before you make your
decisions but it's your decision if
that's what makes a difference to
members the idea of conditions is if
something that just prevents you from
granting consent but could be dealt with
as a condition then that's why condition
exist to make the difference between
something being unacceptable and
acceptable subject to these conditions
so if you want condition 11 improved
with details of um the the warning
system and the measures I can word that
into that uh re condition 11 for the
purposes of the decision
matters colle have already um like we
did last time written it out I think I
can do you want to read it because yeah
we can read it out to members if they
wish what we've worked from this
so just in addition to condition 11 just
finish it off details of an emergency
flood plan should be submitted to an
agreed in writing with the local
planning Authority and shall be
implemented on site and maintained in
perpetuity and then that will give
details for us to then agree which
should include more expensive
information for us to look at um when
we're looking to discharge the condition
around um how those people would be
warned okay members be happy with that I
would be happy with that because people
do die from flood
very quickly it comes up on
you counc
Williams thank you chairman If This Were
to be permanent housing new permanent
housing I would certainly have serious
concerns there must be thousands of
homes around the coastline that could be
at risk if we have the the wrong weather
conditions um I would thoroughly support
this and follow um officers
recommendations something that we need
in this area there's very little holiday
accommodation and this is only holiday
LS it's get it into perspective thank
you thank you councelor
ward yeah thank you very much chairman I
I do understand everything the members
have said about holiday lets and it's
temporary and and all the rest of it but
the one thing that's missing from this
whole report is anything from Fire and
Rescue Services how long would it take
them to get to there in the event of a
serious issue happening that's not in
this report and that's what concerns me
everything we've got bats we've got
everything in there except that and and
that really does worry me what happens
in an emergency how long will it take
fire and rescue to get to anywhere like
that to actually assist those people
there uh my Gap feeling on that is that
it would affect everyone in that little
area there but I would ask uh Mr strank
if he could come back on that maybe
thank you chairman um far and rescue
aren't a consulier on this type of thing
but your emergency planner has been
involved so we would expect him to take
account of the the risks and the
likelihood um because you don't have to
have massive depths to be a threat you
know I think six inches of water can
knock you off your feet and cause you to
be rescued in a boat you know that sort
of thing but because the Emer council's
emergency planner is happy you know that
the plans and things that they have and
the arrangements and the equipment the
Emergency Services Etc would allow
people to be rescued if they need then
he's happy that in the plan that he has
for
pagam annexing this property to that
plan is not such a problem that he would
he would object so it's because he is
he's content with the proposal as to not
undermine or cause significant added
risk there's always a risk um which is
why he's recommending approval and why
the environment agency is saying well
look if the emergency planner council's
own emergency guy is happy then they
could sort of live with
it counc w thank you thank you
chairman I'm finding this extremely
frustrating to be quite honest with you
I really am um insurance I take it that
the owner of the let will be totally
responsible for the insurance I know
it's not a planning issue at all I do
recognize that but I'm looking at safety
I'm looking at so many different things
which I believe we should be looking at
are we taking responsibility or is the
owner taking responsibility and I would
assume that the owner has to furnish the
insurance in a flood plane as far as
this is concerned so that would be part
of his duty to be able to do that but if
it's coming back on us because basically
the report says the environment agency
says we're not happy with anything but
if the planning Authority is happy with
it so are we that that's what they're
basically saying I'm I'm not
particularly happy with that at all at
all I have to
say thank you councel well I think there
are occasions when we just have to
accept accept that uh
planning substantial planning issues
aren't covered by some of the things
that we are actually concerned about um
there are things that we would have to
take outside of the committee um to
ensure that various things are in place
I I hear where you're coming from but I
think that the the issue is more a case
of yes you are concerned I hear your
concerns we've all probably got the same
concerns but it's not something that is
material to the decision that we've got
to make today uh Council
cable thank you Mr chairman I think the
committee have got to bear in mind that
this is a resubmission of um an
application that has already been
approved um and if it gets turned down I
think we will be on a Sticky Wicket on
an pill um as regards flooding in the
area um there is a little bit of surface
flooding I know the pub down the road
has a problem with the flooding but if
there was a major flood in that area the
whole of pagam is in a lot of trouble
there's a lot of small Bungalows there
and they're all other similar levels but
if there was a 53 type situation there
Not only would pagam go I think most of
the villages in the area we would have
big problem with um so that's a problem
which the local parish councils and
everybody else has got in order so
looking at that and the conditions
that's been put in by um the officers I
have no problem in recommending that and
I would therefore put forward that this
application is
approved thank you Council conable I'd
just like to add before we move to you
uh we'll go for a second or a minute I
just want to actually you make one um
when we had the um site visit previously
and I know there was concern from
residents there um when we went to the
site uh the applicant did actually
confirm that he's bringing the gate
further down the drive so as people
waiting to come onto the property will
not be leaving their engin sticking over
by someone's bedroom who's in the
locality there can I just confirm that
that is still part of this application
chairman condition 17 of the
recommendation covers that as it did
actually on the earlier application so
we're seeking the submission of details
um to reposition the gate and the access
track so the applicant will do a revised
plan submit that for officers to clear
if we're unhappy with that then we'll
ask him to rethink if we're happy with
that then we can approve it under the
terms of that of that condition so it is
covered Chair by condition 17 thank you
very much okay so councelor oh sorry
councilor
Williams I was just GNA ask that so okay
we have a motion to uh approve uh with
Council coun seconded by councelor
Williams those in favor would you please
indicate can I just ask as well um is
that uh also in relation to that amended
condition 11 as well yes sorry that will
be including that
yeah those in favor please
indicate
okay thank you those
against thank you any abstentions I
don't think so no
okay
that's
okay for eight against two that
application is approved thank
you right now I want to move on to um
I'm going to change the order a little
bit because uh I've been asked to
because we have um residents here for
item I believe it's item
nine uh yes item
nine ccel
sh after seeing all the emails we've had
the odd emails that we was required to
have the site visit and it didn't happen
and I'm not pointing a finger or at
anyone can we actually defer this item
until we get a site visit please are you
suggesting that as a motion I am okay do
I have a second there Council award okay
those in favor of deferring for a site
visit please indicate if you're in favor
item this item nine Brook
Road I'm
sorry those
against thank you any
abstentions okay
that is seven for two against no
abstentions so uh we have that one
deferred uh for a site visit thank you
and I do apologize to those who actually
come for speaking um but that will be in
a future
[Music]
meeting
okay so we move on to item seven then
which is uh
23862 428 Chestnut close hotley clear
Buckley will present the report thank
you CLA so this application is for an
extension to an existing dwelling and
other minor works it is before members
for consideration as the applicant is a
relation of a member of staff at Watcher
District Council as you can see from the
location plan the site is located within
the residential area of Hawley
surrounded by other dwellings the
property is located on Chestnut close
located
here the site comprises of a semi touch
Bungalow with Dormers the was for a
single story flat roof rear extension of
the property with roof lights so that's
a single story element here those are
the roof lights um roof lights the
existing Western elevation here um of
the pudi Gable end to the rear of the
property the creation of an additional
side entrance to the Eastern side of the
dwelling and a new window to the Eastern
elevation so as you can see here the
extension will provide for a larger open
plan Lounge kitchen
Diner as you can see from the proposed
elevation plans the proposed extension
would protrude from the current existing
rear building line by 3 MERS so as you
can see in that location there that's
where the extension would be the design
of the extension would be flat roof
using cream render and white upvc
windows and doors so the key material
planning considerations are impact on
the character of the area residential
amenity Garden size parking ecology and
trees looking at impact on the character
of the area the proposed overall is the
proposal overall is considered to
positively contribute to the existing
dwelling by way of external finishes and
is of appropriate scale mass and design
I would not give rise to a detrimental
impact on the character of the
application site nor would it be
detrimental the appearance of the street
seam looking at residential amenity
overall it is not considered that the
extension would have an adverse impact
on the occupi of nav properties in terms
of overshadowing overlooking or any loss
of privacy on Garden size sufficient
Garden area would remain with a proposal
in place in accordance with
spd2 and then parking the proposed
extension would be to the rear of the
property and would therefore not result
in any changes to the parking provision
at the property and ecology inuries the
bat survey declaration form submitted
indicates that there is not likely to be
harm to bats or their habitat as a
result of the proposed works there are
no trees located on or close to the site
that will be impacted this application
is recommended for approval subject to
the conditions outlined in the officers
report thank you
Clea
there are no public speakers for this
item uh the W members Council belon
councel Carter and councel conable
councelor C you're the only W member
here would you like to speak on the
item sorry I've been corrected here um
does do any of the visiting members want
to speak on the item no okay thank
you c c
thank you Mr chairman um I can't see
anything wrong with this um extension
and I believe this is only just been
called in or it's been referred because
of a relationship with the owners with a
member of Rochford staff and and in the
normal case this would have been rubber
stamped and gone through um it's a very
small extension and I understand why
it's been uh referred to us and on the
basis of all that unless anyone else has
got any objection I would like to
recommend to the council or this
committee that this application is
approved before we take that to the vote
then anyone else wish to speak
Council hang
on does anyone want to actually speak on
the mo on this application second I'll
second the
motion okay I was going to come to
that okay councel shw you second it
though
sorry just to just to clarify members in
terms of what's been said completely
understand what you mean Council cable
but just for clarity the delegated
authority in the usual circumstance had
the applicant not been related to
someone who works for the council it
would have been recommended in the usual
way through the weekly list and decided
on in that way rather than rubber
stamped in terms of what that means but
the the um the the Constitution requires
it to come to committee on that basis so
I understand what you mean just but just
for complete CL thank you for clearing
up my inadequate English and will
confer councelor Williams I believe you
want to speak yeah thank you this so I
presume this would be permitted
development is that the case or not no
it's not permitted development but it
just would have gone through the
delegated process of officers
considering and assessing the
application internally um had it not
been that it was a member of muchard
Staff okay thank
you okay members uh the application has
been
um uh put forward and seconded so so in
that case the recommendation is to
approve the application subject to the
conditions set out on pages 7.1 to 7.2
of the report uh can I ask all those in
favor to indicate
please that is unanimous so that
item that item is
approved now I have to leave
you um the officer in the report will
actually um
clarify
why um and
um just uh give us a moment while we uh
while we just swap around and I will
leave you in the capable hands of my
vice chair thank
you
chairman would you need a vice chairman
for this
item no no the vice chairman will
automatically
um does the committee feel we need a
vice chair for this
item okay I I have asked for a vice
chair in the past when I haven't I've
been without one because we've had some
pretty um intense applications at the
time but I I think that uh you should be
able to cope with this one okay
sorry
so this application is a full
sorry thank you members for uh for that
very short interlude um okay we're
moving on to agenda item number eight
which is
23048 full which is the workshop at
glazbrook Farm Canon Road asend for
which our chair has uh retired from this
agenda item and CLA will present the
officer's report for us thank you thank
you
apologies this application is a full
planning application to demolish the
existing buildings on land and sever the
land and erect three detached six
bedroom dwellings with Associated access
car parking bin and cycle storage as you
can see from the location plan the site
is glazbrook Farm located on Canon Road
in ashingdon it is surrounded by open
land um with Canen road to its northern
boundary and it's located within the
green belt there is a dwelling dwelling
to the South glazbrook Farmhouse which
shares the same access to the
application site so that's just down
here and the access comes down this side
here the site is in commercial use with
mostly storage in operation but also a
joinery workshop this item is brought
before the committee in the interest of
openness and transparency because the
chairman of the development committee is
employed and has premises on the
application
site this plan shows the existing layer
of the site as you can see here there
are six
buildings so on this side here we've got
one two three four five six there we go
six buildings all located on that side
here that's what we have on um existing
on the site at the
moment they vary in size um and the site
also has a large amount of hard standing
located within it on this plan the
largest is building one um as you can
see here so that's building one located
there um on this particular plan but
then we have two and three which are far
more modest ins sizing as you can see
here all three are described as being
used for storage purposes so then
looking at number
two this okay so building four is the
largest on the site as you can see here
that's the longest one here um this is
used as a joining workshop and store and
is two story in
height and then buildings five and six
are also moded and scale and this wild
is being used for storage and there's a
garage those those are the two located
to the South
[Music]
there so this is a proposed lout uh the
proposal is to demolish the six
buildings and construct three detach
dwellings as you can see here the
existing access onto Canon Road will
remain will be used for the three new
dwellings ensuring continued right of
access to The Farmhouse to the South so
that's this access road coming down here
they would all have their own garden
areas and parking spaces along with bin
and cycle stores so you can see the
gardens here and they would all have
these parking areas just to the side
here and I zoom in just slightly and you
can see these are the the bin and cycle
stores just to the side of the parking
spaces the dwellings would be large
shallow style properties with four
picture of dorms to the front and back
and a Gable projection to the front and
rear to break the continuity of the
front and rear elevations they would
measure 7.7 m in height and look at the
floor plans just
quickly so they would have six bedrooms
along with four bathrooms an open plan
Lounge kitchen Diner drawing room
utility two restrooms office and
dressing room to the master
bedroom so the key material planning
considerations are green belt
sustainability layout scale and
appearance residential amenity Garden
size
technical housing standards flooding
drainage refuse and waste storage
contaminated land trees impact on
highway safety and
ecology so looking at the Green Belt
part G to paragraph 149 of the mppf
allows for the limited infilling or the
partial or complete Redevelopment of
previously development land whether
redundant or in continuing use this is
the only possible exception that
requires consideration here it is
considered that the site does represent
previously developed land
however the proposal is considered to
have a greater impact on the openness
formed by the 270 M squar increase in
floor space that is proposed above the
existing floor space of the buildings
currently on the site it is not
considered that the list of very special
circumstances outlined by the applicant
would outweigh the harm identified the
proposal was therefore considered to
represent inappropriate development and
is recommended for refusal on Green Belt
grounds looking at sustainability The
Proposal is considered to represent
sustainable development due to its
location close to ashingdon primary
school and ashingdon road with good
transport connections to nearby towns
layout scal and appearance it is
considered that the design proposed
dwelling houses are in keeping with the
local vincular um the design and
appearance is overall considered to be
acceptable here on residential amenity
the nearest dwelling is approximately 85
meters away to the South The Proposal
would not be considered to have a
detrimental impact on this property the
cting of the dwellings and the lack of
penetration to side elevations would
ensure that there would be no
impact between the proposed dwellings on
Garden sizes the proposed dwellings
provide well in excess of 100 met
squared criteria within
sbd2 on the technical housing standards
the dwellings meet the necessary minimum
floor area and storage requirements set
by
government looking at flooding the
application site is located entirely in
flood zone one where there is the lowest
probability of flooding from rivers and
the Sea and to where development should
be
directed on drainage development on
sites such as this can generally reduce
the permeability of at least part of the
site and changes the site's response to
rainfall in the event that Planning
Commission is approved it is considered
reasonable to attach a condition to the
decision notice requiring the submission
of a satisfactory drainage scheme in
order to ensure that any service will to
run off from the site is sufficiently
discharged on refu and waste storage
there is sufficient space within the
applicants curtilage to accommodate the
refug bins bin storage is shown on the
layout plans provided
on contaminated land due to the
sensitive nature of the proposed
development it is considered that the
application should have been accompanied
with a a contaminated land report to
ascertain the likelihood of any
contaminants being present this
represents a further recommended reason
for refusal here on trees there are
mature trees located on boundaries of
the application site furthermore there
is a small cop of trees immediately to
the south of the application and
numerous trees located to the east an
arbic cultural impact assessment has not
been submitted so is not sufficient
information to determine whether the
existing trees will be impacted or if
any Works will need to be conducted on
the existing trees this represents a
further recommended reason for refusal
here on highway safety County highways
rais no objection to the proposal
subject to conditions each threading
will provide two driveway parking spaces
in accordance with the parking standards
criteria along with the bike store and
finally on ecology as there is suitable
habitat on the site to support protected
species a phase one ecological survey of
the site would be required as a minimum
to establish the presence or absence of
protected species and to ensure that
appropriate mitigation could be secured
if necessary to ensure that no harm
would be caused to protected species as
a result of the development no eological
survey of this particular site has been
provided and therefore it cannot be
determined whether there is the presence
of protected species on the site this
represents a further recommended re for
refusal here with regards to offsite
ecology the applicant has paid the
financial contribution to mitigate harm
to the coastal European designated sites
the recommendation is that planning
Mission be refused for the four reasons
outlined in the officer's recommendation
but also summarized as follows number
one lack of an arbc cultural impact
assessment number two lack of an
ecological survey number three lack of a
contaminated land report and number four
inappropriate development in the green
belt thank you thank
you oh thank you
CLA uh there are no public speakers for
this
item
[Music]
um get this right uh W member councelor
constable do you is there any comment
you wish to
make
yes um right paragraph is
on um this application is completely out
of uh character for the area um my
objections on it are are a couple mainly
over development also I'd like to add to
the conditions um that the officers have
recommended against it is the loss of
employment in the area um also I think
it was mentioned that the track leading
past the houses also leads to the farm I
have great concerns for safety there uh
with tractors going past the houses if
they have children that play out there
or run out um in that situation with a
tractor around there there would be mud
there would be all sorts of problems um
for a later date but mainly I would like
to add to the conditions the loss of
employment in the area if that's
acceptable I think just coming back on
both of those points um the loss of
employment will probably be quite
difficult for us to put forward partly
because when we're accepting
um when we've confirmed it's acceptable
within our offic of recommendation as
previously developed land in the green
belt that can be in existing and
continuous use at the moment so the fact
that there are existing uses on the site
um puts us in sort of a difficult
position in terms of the green belt
argument because we in our officers
report we are accepting that it can be
considered PDL previously developed land
um so that's probably what I'd comment
back on that and with regards to the
safety of the roadway because it's
already in existing use where it's got
commercial operation there already um I
think again we we haven't had any
objection from County highways on the
usage of that um and the relationship
between the dwellings um proposed and
the existing Farm to the rear so I think
again um we'd have difficulty in raising
any issue with regard to the highway
element okay moving on can I just ask do
we have any visiting members that um
wish to speak
no
okay uh I'm very sorry sir you not down
as register as um somebody who has asked
her to speak at this
item no no didn't okay well I've not got
anything recorded for that so um all I
can say to you is that um I can't allow
you to speak on this agenda item thank
you moving on councelor Shaw thank you
thank you for the officers for this
report I understand why you once it
refused could we actually get this
deferred until we and you ask for the
reports that you're are you're actually
waiting for is that an option I'd like
the office just come back and advise yes
or no on that if not we'll move from
what you're saying thank you
um whil sometimes we do think that's a
reasonable approach if there are other
reasons which we think um which don't
require survey work to be submitted so
we've got the inappropriate development
one um we haven't obviously gone back in
this case and asked for um further work
to to ask for deferment or ask for an
extension of time to consider the
application because we've got this
inappropriate develop development in the
green Bel um reason as well thank you
thank you for clarifying thank you yeah
I was just so it wouldn't be reasonable
for us to expect the applicant to go
away and do further reports when there's
already that inappropriate development
reason for refusal on the table I think
what they need to do is revisit the
scheme
[Music]
yeah uh thank you thank you councelor
you're moving on to councelor
Ward yeah thank you very much chairman
um I think that the material reasons for
refusal are adequate and i would support
the officers as far as this refusal is
concerned thank you very much chairman
thank
you councilor FD thank you chairman um
where about is name is Bop to
this so there's one on ashing I think
and how far away is that so Ash is if I
get the location plan
up doesn't it's not quite zoomed out
enough but um further along here we've
got ashon Primary School haven't we and
it's it's in close proximity to that I
think isn't it I
believe I I don't know but I do get a
little bit annoyed when people say good
transport links and the buses along
there as far as I'm aware they they're
not
good so I get annoyed when you say it's
good good transport links when it
clearly
hasn't I think when it comes to
sustainability which I think is sort of
what we're kind of getting at really um
some of the key considerations are not
just suppose connection to Highway also
proximity to local services so because
this is in close proximity to the
primary school in particular as well um
that's why it's considered to still
represent sustainable development um in
this
case okay but you can't buy your fruit
and veget from primary school
okay can I just ask is there anyone that
wishes to speak before we move on no
okay uh the recommendation is to refuse
the application subject to the
conditions set out on pages 8.1 to 8.2
of the report can those members in favor
please raise their
hands
that's unanimous thank you and I'd like
to welcome the chair back to um his seat
at the table thank
you actually I'll say the chair of walk
thank you very much that is indeed the
end of the meeting thank you
members meeting closed at
8:31